Fred was going to be here last week but
you were celebrating 400 years of uh
that company zon symbols yeah yes they
asked me to host this event yeah and in
hosting a symbol event or a 400 years of
that symbol event yeah and we're talking
about drum symbols if you're not if
you're just listening to this um what is
involved in like 400 years of it's
really funny because I mean gu it's not
that funny it's just it's so specific it
really 400 years I keep thinking a
Turkish company started making symbols
400 years ago
1623 well everybody knows that but no
not everybody knows that what the math
we take for
granted we take for granted that we
could just do that really quickly
there's some people who would take them
a moment to kind of go okay was that
1723 was that
1523 you're right you know so in
1623 yeah why did they need a were were
there drum sets I don't think there were
drum sets it was just a it was just
percussion that's a good question I
really don't know we started why would
they have
started like well they had gongs before
drum sets true so maybe it evolved from
there
and and then they called you Fred they
said this is 400 years which is a an
incredible Milestone yeah of one
specific symbol comp they just make
symbols right they just make a symbol
that's it that's it and and you said I
would love to yes host yeah and and was
it a big was there a big turnout it was
gigantic it was like this theater in
Boston they're based out of Boston this
Turkish company is based in Boston yeah
they they moved to America I think in
the early 1900s okay I could be wrong
maybe late
1800s um and there's all these it's like
a drum nerd thing like they're just
nerds drum fans and did you do cuz I
loved I went to see you in concert and
if you get a chance if he's playing in
your are you do are you touring at all
yeah yeah I Tour all the time yeah I saw
a show that was and I think you taped it
for uh was it on Netflix your drum yeah
yeah that was amazing thank you I had no
idea because I know nothing about really
I I enjoy music but I know nothing about
music and to think it was so um
surprising to think that you were doing
a such a specific topic and it was so
interesting so funny so um
entertaining it was and so weirdly
creative that you would just focus it's
kind of like 400 years of them thank you
that was amazing I appreciate it no I
appreciate it I was in the audience and
everybody you don't have to be a
musician if you no no no it's it's more
like about people's uh experience with
music like going to see bands and stuff
so you don't have to see you don't have
to be a musician
he